[Applause]
i blame them for everything all right
happy wednesday everyone we got a great
show tonight good to see lisa booth is
back
yeah you've been clapping
they're not booing them they're boothing
them
it's good to see her especially after
what happened to her last night
[Music]
[Music]
i have some bruises yes a little too far
to the left
you know clumsy people should stick to
dancing on the floor really quickly all
right
now you be quiet i'm trying to do a
monologue
so it's been really hard to gauge the
vice president's performance during the
afghanistan fiasco mainly because she's
been harder to find than a non-binary
taliban leader which basically means he
sleeps with both women and goats
it's almost like she was abducted by
aliens and not the ones pouring across
our southern border
honestly i'm starting
to miss her
her gravitas her sincerity her
compassion towards looters and arsonists
but also i really miss her soothing
laughs
i'll be honest i'm going through cackle
withdrawal
but i've been making do with this
come my comic co-horse and crime
i love him
true we'd have more luck finding cesar
romero at a laundromat in queens than
finding kamala anywhere
guess that means it's time for
in search of
kamala harris
with your host
sarah jessica parker
[Music]
that was a mistake
welcome to in search of kamala harris
and for tonight i'm your host sarah
jessica parker so while the country
endured a week and a half of horrible
news
we heard that kamala went on a trip to
vietnam vietnam why does that name ring
a bell
what happened over there not sure but
she left faster than the last u.s
helicopter out of saigon in 1975. she
stopped over at pearl harbor fair enough
but if she's interested in military
tragedies there is one person she's
presiding over currently
but i guess it's fitting kamala's
approval rating is also a dive bombing
zero
then there was an event that was closed
to the press
what happened there no idea it was
closed to the press something i just
said three seconds ago
sometimes i really wish you were
listening to me
fact is harris has been as quiet as don
lemon after he sees his own ratings
she's been as closed mouth as our
president when he loses his choppers
this is interesting for as we were once
told she was supposed to be the real
commander-in-chief not the old guy
currently trying to put kleenex boxes on
his feet and combing his hair with a
toilet brush
as joe koncha points out in the hill
which is a website not a mound of dirt
she was a historic consequential figure
he cites politico's headline that
mirrored so many others harris has the
potential to change the face of u.s
politics
sorry this dame couldn't change the lint
filter in your dryer
which is where they harvest joe's hair
but still she was always the anointed
one but now this big deal has vanished
like food left on a tray in a hotel
hallway two doors down from brian
stelter's room
that was a long way for a joke since she
took office she's not held one solo
press conference and she's no longer
doing one-on-one interviews
wow what a powerful display of feminism
and you know hillary's sitting at home
in a robe drinking a bud watching harris
on tv and going are you
me
but one shouldn't be surprised this is
what happens when you're chosen based
only on intersectionality instead of
competence but the dems are in a fix
biden's numbers are dropping like pigeon
poop on a statue but harrises are worse
as concha points out a recent usa today
poll has the vp at 35 percent approval
40 54 disapproval that's insane for a vp
just seven months in harris is 19 points
underwater if she sunk any lower she'd
qualify for shark week
and she hasn't done anything memorable
it's a rare feat to be both invisible
and unpopular which might be why her
secret service code name is silent but
deadly
she's the human version of carbon
monoxide
but maybe it's a strategy the more you
see of her the worse it gets so keeper
under wraps
you know it's kind of like michael moore
in a thong
yeah you're right
nothing is like michael moore in a thong
and i apologize for placing that image
into your heads
anyway it puts the dems in quite a
pickle joe doesn't look like a second
termer in fact the action in vegas
doesn't have sleepy joe making it to
thanksgiving many of you think he's
sleepy now wait till he's had some
turkey
biden completing his term this man can't
even complete his sentences
and when the strategy for your successor
is keeping her out of sight then maybe
you should rethink that successor unless
this is somehow planned joe is publicly
bad kamala is nowhere to be found
keeping her under wraps as he implodes
that might make sense with inflation
crime covid spending and now afghanistan
perhaps the real strategy is making joe
look so bad he exits earlier than
expected like a starting pitcher who
gives up eight runs in the first inning
that's a sports metaphor lisa
if that's the democrats plan i've got
two words for them mission accomplished
i got two other words for the dems but
this is a family show but after so many
bad things happening so fast maybe
anything different looks good
including even someone you can't even
find like kamala the democratic party
reminds me of me
in my single days you know after having
eight drinks and i'm at last call i'd go
home with a panda
and during that vacation in singapore i
did
[Applause]
at 4 00 am he's already giving farmers
garbage men and meth heads all the news
they need fox and friends first
co-anchor todd pyro
and while cause up early newsing she's
still out boozing republican strategist
and foster's contributor lisa booth
and her 12-step program is falling down
three or four at a time boxes
contributor cat temp
finally
his audience is always in stitches
because they stab themselves after
seeing his stand up comedian joe mackey
all right lisa good to see you slightly
sober
that's what you think
just kidding i know no yeah just kidding
i've used that line you know why do you
i i threw out a couple of theories on
why we're not seeing harris at all vp
harris do you have any theories why
she's out of sight i think joe biden
hates her ooh that could be it because
let me think about it if you had to deal
with kamala harris on a daily basis or
with any sort of frequency wouldn't you
want her out of the picture as much as
possible i would send her away every
single day i would have her on trips
every week i'd send her to north korea
she can hang him out with kim jong-un i
mean if this is someone you had to deal
with on a daily basis wouldn't you want
her out of sight as much as possible but
i think to your monologue you're right
there's a very real possibility that
neither joe biden or kamala harris are
the democrat nominee in 2024. yeah you
know what you made me realize that
president biden sent her to the border
as punishment for him calling her a
racist i literally think they hate him
remember the race when he called it when
he said i was that little girl to him
and so he's like
now i really like biden and his wife i
think that might have been dr jill
though but he's like going
you know remember that time she called
me racist maybe she should go down and
deal with the disenfranchised down at
the border if she's so progressive so he
sent her down there and now i'm
beginning to like the guy although he
probably did that unintentionally taught
todd it's good to see you're still awake
had a long day so far um is this a big
problem for the democrats it's a huge
problem and i can't decide to your
monologue's point whether this is
intentional or this is a failure and
that's a common question we have so
often with this administration is that
diana's saying was this purposeful was
this just a mess up some combination of
both what i just can never wrap my hands
around and my contribution to this
thought is this she was a former
prosecutor right yet they hesitate to
put her in any kind of an ad-lib
situation because we saw the lester holt
interview lester holt isn't clarence
darrow here the pinnacle of
jurisprudence he asked the question like
what are you doing is i i've never been
to europe what
what you know so i that that is very
concerning if
it's got to be a really bad place in
europe not a good place like you're not
you're not going to scandinavia although
i don't know
everything in europe is pretty good
right yeah yeah i mean they've got the
dollars these days what especially
compared to here
anti-american you make me sick
so joe uh do you think commonly will be
the choice for the democrats for
president in 2024 i doubt it greg biden
harris is like when a snake fights a
python
they're only hurting each other
well i'll tell you why things going down
here it reminds me of back in high
school
when the kids would throw a no parents
alcohol party and i would call the
police because i wasn't invited
and as i watched from the bushes i
noticed that everyone would run away
when the cops showed up because they
wanted to get away from where the
trouble was and i think that's what what
the vice president harris is doing she's
saying oh i was in the room when joe
biden planned the withdrawal and now
she's saying look at all the rooms i'm
in that don't have joe biden planning
stuff
[Laughter]
maybe the room she was in is a time-out
room it doesn't matter you just can't
have that just cover the room yes cat
she has a similar issue that you have we
can't tell if it's intentional or it's
just on purpose wait those are the same
things what a shoe
oh you name one
the laugh thing because i also have an
annoying laugh people always tell me
stop with that laugh as if like i chose
this one you have a husky laugh you have
a husky like yeah you laugh like a 14
year old boy yes yes like beavis and
butthead
yeah bad laugh oh why
uh but you should hear her in the office
it's
people cry when they hear it
but i look with kamala
i think that there's an alternate way of
looking at this that she's actually
doing everything as vice president that
she was chosen to do because if as you
said she was chosen just because she
checks off certain boxes identity wise
then by that logic all she needs to do
is just exist right keep existing and as
far as we know she still does you know
it's interesting that both of both of
them served a purpose in winning she
ticked the boxes and he was the trojan
horse of moderation right so he that's
why i i i don't like seeing dems turning
on joe because joe
who i don't know if joe actually wanted
to run for president right he did it was
like you know he was he wanted to go
hang out somewhere yeah
preferably naked somewhere that's a
rumor by the way i don't have anything
to substantiate that is there anything
you'd like to tell us
it was that time one weekend but i don't
want to get into delaware's a crazy
place hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else